I'll be going everyone goodbye here
welcome back to abduction the freaking
longest mod I ever played and we're
gonna turf its fire dirt butter shuttle
throw share I couldn't work if you think
about it anyway some of you want to see
X here sto add the dollar definitely my
girlfriend made him for me and I want
him to join me while I play this and we
can open this now - progress and it's
only been like a couple of seconds I'm a
genius
I think I am a genius I could be
Einstein think about it
nah probably not because he's German and
I'm Swedish a smart Swedish guy
I think a Swedish guy invented the
French so yeah I'm that guy
I don't trust you ma'am
I think we got to put it here
ah are you serious oh all right hmm
I'm a genius I'm a genius here we have
to
and
I think I might have to replay some
parts in here no I know I know I know I
know I remember on
I remember do you remember
nananananana September Danner
so there's one up there that we
collected but it didn't say so I have to
replay that later but first of all we
have the puzzle part yes and it's 15 up
and four down I think I think what do
you think is I don't know let's find
Stefano everyone keeps asking for
Stefano but I can't find him tell us the
fauna to come back oh sorry
when Stefano comes back he'll come back
when he's ready I can tell right anyway
we're gonna go in here we're gonna solve
this puzzle cuz ah barrels right and I'm
a friend I guess I'm not a genius cuz I
always forget to anyway like go I'm
excited I just think there's one lamp
here hiding somewhere alright there's
not a lamp okay I have to use my super
nice um and I have no oil haven't add
oil for like decades or something let's
see her diary snow notes for 15 so for a
450 now or for up and stop moving barrel
it's so freakin hard to see stop moving
stop Jesus freakin circus but I hate you
barrel I hate you so much
alright let's do this I think that's how
how in the fricative frack yes I said
freaky Frank is there a problem
that's ah thank you finally some light
I'm sure as I've took some time at SIA I
am disappointed stay stay
awk you are so freaking annoying hate
bells okay now I can see there's a 1
there and a 3 there while in a - since 4
is probably easier to solve
there's I can think of two combinations
one combination yeah there's three
different combinations so it's either
this and this but that will make too
much I think 10 plus 10 plus I'll be 14
so it'll be this that will be too little
oh come on you freaking light I hate
sorry why am I so short [ __ ] barrel
come here
[ __ ] [ __ ] Daniel sorry I'm kind of
pissed today I want to see okay so this
is forward it'll be way too much [ __ ]
I'm so [ __ ] barrels I hate him but
could it be four down
if it's four down then there's only two
combinations and that's there there
nope five six five one not it's
impossible what about you
okay so seven plus six it's too much
no it's not I'm stupid ads yeah why is
this [ __ ] try it whatever I saw go
down you oh oh man oh man
my eight puzzles though much
oh I can see now oh I got like
I don't understand I really really
really don't understand this doesn't
work I'm out of ideas and yep doesn't
work doesn't work okay four plus [ __ ]
lightning
six seven eight nine ten
it's too little it stole it
I'm a genius
yeah I'm genius wha
oh [ __ ] why did I do this whether I do
this [ __ ] he's gonna come in here it is
don't look at it sir
[ __ ] he's so sexy his voice are like a
calling for me I miss the fun oh I miss
piggy I miss blue oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm so screwed
I'm a little screwed oh but oh man oh
man I just don't oh [ __ ]
I'm so fine oh I just want to go out I
just want to hang out oh [ __ ] why did I
go here I'm not even supposed to go
there oh [ __ ] I have to go back oh
please come please be gone please be
gone please me I'm pooping I'm pissing
on people I buy I don't even know why
like you see here card sign here okay
let's go let's go let's go let's go I'm
a genius
it's okay and now this yes yes
okay Indiana Jones moment yes just don't
touch it
okay I got this
we replace it with the question anyone
bring it
oh no sir monster nope
okay fine with me now we have one more
and which we already collected so I
usually go by if I have to replay
something you better [ __ ] really
watch it but I'm not sure I don't trust
you
then I gotta sacrifice my penis
which we'll do later first I don't
remember if it's upstairs or downstairs
I remember how it looks like no it
sounds sir I'm a genius it's okay did
you know it was down sir - no you did
with your monkey it's okay
that's okay I'm sure I know it was
downstairs
Hey
but let's make this quick I super duper
quick right that's deal yeah maybe we'll
find Stefano
I'm excited
what has he been up to I've been
listening all right the Stefan is there
I just need to remember where I came
from because I have a tendency of not
remembering but I think we're just gonna
go hey yo I hear heavy breathing in the
background that's cool that's fine
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] go in here
no problem I already play this and he
still scares the [ __ ] out of me Oh
no problem
mmm-hmm no problem is this really where
Oh mm-hmm
all right it's stuck and then we'll go
really
I thought
No isn't it though yes
boy yeah but oh shut up then we went in
here right and then we picked up that
and then he's like finally journey and
I'm like nope
and then I even knew that was gonna
happen
[ __ ] it's cool it's cool I got this no
problem ah problem oh [ __ ] we already
been through this
I needed closets just don't find me
again please
oh but he doesn't like classes but from
my amnesia experience he likes closets
[ __ ] it's dark in here there's not
someone else
uh no no he's such an idiot
luckily this go here pick it up I'm oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] no [ __ ] Sherlock
what the [ __ ] I didn't see him the lost
ai ai why don't was supposed to do do I
have it yeah I have it
it's cool but I had to replay this
corridor is it in here no
how do I get out of here this is where I
came from and then we could oh yeah okay
so yeah hey I just want to get them I
think I remember I'm not sure let's go
Savan oh I miss you I guess we'll have
to find her some other time
right now I just want to start to finish
this mod because it's been like one day
a lot of parts
[ __ ] I'm all sweaty okay
now unfortunately I have to sacrifice
our penis I know it sucks Danielle but
you gotta do it think well I'm part of
the team
yeah
all right
yellow asked me what it feels like
staring at the sky so Vendela telling
Kurt Russell on me this ain't real life
I'll be making good on my promises
honesty's pop it in slide if it is
missing but I realize I could be better
than I was light on my feet
cooking up the song when we fire up